hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry
we're gonna check out a clip from Batman
V Superman that do you bleed clip do you
bleed before the bleeding begins I want
to mention this is a sponsored video
from Full Sail University sale full sale
to film school peeps of film school
because film is exciting it's a
rewarding experience so if you don't
know how to get involved with the film
business or if you're not sure what type
of direction you're looking for Full
Sail University can help you out that's
right they got a diverse curriculum you
can figure out what your expertise are
you can work with professional equipment
see what you like to do in the
moviemaking process and learn all about
it the campus undergraduate film program
it introduces you to so many different
roles where in the end you know you can
help with deciding whether you're an
editor or director or even a camera
operator yeah and if you can't you know
for whatever reason attend two classes
at the campus they have online courses -
they have a digital film program now I
think where you can learn the most
cutting-edge digital photography and
digital cinematography yeah if you look
up a lot of the graduates you know just
within the last year alone people have
worked on like minions Jurassic world
Avengers age of Ultron and frozen let it
go to full sale so if you want to find
out more about these programs at Full
Sail University visit the link in the
description box which will say all that
edu slash YouTube to learn more anyway
let's start bleeding
what are you doing
[Music]
then
[Music]
next time we shudder like the sky don't
go to it but that is dead buried
consider this mercy yeah tell me
[Music]
do you fight
yeah CG enhanced eyes again yeah I'm not
oh wow make some commentary 44 seconds
long it's like so white it's like your
eyes you hold that up there just to be
like look out
[Music]
his voice sounds so weird next time they
shine you're like this guy
don't go to it actually that sounds
weird a second time the Batman barely
consider this mercy tell me
[Music]
employee
[Music]
okay listen I have looked into my
feelings like a good human being this is
leaving the goodness is leaving looking
at my feelings because I'm being an open
man about how I feel I can be even more
analytical about this in this clip I
could there are things about where I'm
like now you see some people have
misjudged our reaction to the second
trailer because you know what I've 2016
this is still my most anticipated movie
and if all the movies come out this year
I'm still going if I had to choose one
movie this year it's gonna be Batman V
Superman okay just because of the
context behind it all this all the
things leading up to it I gotta watch it
I'm sure regardless of whatever details
are nitpicks or even obvious stuff that
it might be I still think it's gonna be
a cool looking film and I still think
it's gonna be fun perhaps it's just
because you are so excited for it you
know youyou want it to be good unless
you're noticing things yeah more
intensely in the outset the way how I
feel about this is sort of similar to
how a lot of hardcore Star Wars fans
felt about the force awakens in the
sense that you know you ever meet those
force awakens the Star Wars fans were
like here's what I would have wanted the
film to be and it's like well do that
with I'm sorry that wasn't the film you
should like and sorry it wasn't the
script you wanted but hey just judge the
work for what it is and I feel like in
the past I was sort of doing that with
this going here's what I want it to be
though instead of just accepting it on
some merits and I feel like this is
gonna be a hard film to truly satisfy
the masses and the hardcore comic book
fans because granted it's particularly
based off of specific graphic novel of
Frank Miller's still there's gonna be
you know like here's how it should be
going down a lot of people feeling that
way yeah I mean anytime you pair up to
prolific heroes even if there are books
about it like everybody has a very
specific idea on what they want to that
what kind of story they wanted to be the
tone all that yeah stuff you know so
it's a it's a hard balancing act to
please people with a movie like this I
would imagine yes especially after Man
of Steel took Superman in a slightly
different direction that people were
already kind of on the fence about or
some people didn't like and some people
did like so this is gonna be tricky for
them to pull off and this clip is it's
only like three lines longer than the
same clip we receive in the Train yeah I
don't know what you had you feel about
the clip itself then well looking at the
clip itself was I really feel like they
they threw you in at a moment where you
have to watch the scene prior which is
good what went up to it cuz all the
sudden it felt kind of rushed to me and
then it seemed at first the second time
hearing and Henry Cavill voice didn't
sound as strange a little where this I
think that's a loop it must be something
that man's eyes are like you know it's
looking to have the white eyes like the
you know like I know he has like the
mask on I want yeah this works like the
life the lights but it's another thing
where it's like Batman takes the best
eyedrops in the world like what now it's
kind of distracting Lee white to me in
that sense they're supposed to be I
think they're trying to translate that
effect into him at all time I think it's
cuz you see the few poles and stuff and
like it looks a little weird the most I
feel like I'm gonna get from this film
is it's a really entertaining film
that's what I feel like I feel like when
this film was done that's what I at
least want to walk away with I will be
satisfied if I walk away going it was
really entertaining that's sort of the
first thing you would hope for cuz I can
make up for a movie like this that can
make up for a lot is like wow it was
still really enjoyable like that's gonna
be the key for you yeah you know
thinking back on it and remembering it
and taking it with you anywhere yeah
because it's gonna be cool to see them
like go toe-to-toe I mean sorry to bring
this up guys it's just the truth it was
really because I listened to Superman's
threats and I become aware well you guys
are gonna [ __ ] team up in the answer
so I mean [ __ ] but when BAM a squeaks
when Ben Affleck does it I'm like I get
a totally different response someone's
Superman's threatening him was unlike
Superman you again you [ __ ] you
kill him come on yeah you're not gonna
kill him like even if I didn't know they
team up in the end I'm still not gonna
be sitting there like yeah yeah
Superman's really thinking of doing it
mm-hmm but Batman like he looks like I
[ __ ] hate you no I want you dead
immediately it's cool cuz Superman is
standing on top of the Batmobile the
indestructible Batmobile and then you
rips it open holds it and Superman's
like look how powerful I am look at me
and then Batman instead of being like
petrified or like oh no what do I do
he just slowly gets up slowly and calmly
no fear oh yeah just like Bruce means
business do it for me personally
watching this scene here now I feel like
this will be much better with a movie
around it yeah that's what I meant by
how you have to see the the prior scene
especially because it looks like a huge
action scene went down yeah I got there
here I feel like this moment will hit
when we when we've seen the way they're
building the tension in this specific
environment because like we've seen most
of this scene already in various
trailers and they've just added like
three lines from Superman but I want is
clips of Amy Adams and had Diane Lane I
feel like those would be the most
powerful clips it would be nice to know
what's out of this movie but I'm happy
that we're getting some Batman versus
Superman is specific so like we're
getting the stuff that the movie is
supposed to be about this clique
reassured me of what I was already
feeling about Ben Affleck cuz you feel
at least them watching a second time was
able to absorb it a little better when
you're looking at Ben Affleck the fact
that Superman's words aren't
intimidating even though he's saying a
lot of stuff he's saying like here's my
little speech for youth you know my
miniature speech for you Batman is just
like so tell me do you and I love that
because we know Superman is a god yeah I
am a God yet Batman you're he is
threatened you know that's the one thing
I'm getting kind of more now I mean cuz
we talked about this before and like I'm
still kind of trying to figure out
exactly
what it is that Ben Affleck is doing
with Batman because I get a good sense
for his Bruce and I'm getting a slightly
better sense for his Badman here because
he just looks like you see in his face
with this sort of breathing room they
gave this like he does just look pissed
like he looks mad like he's gonna use
that like there's something about the
Superman is is invincible but Batman is
it's mad okay and that makes him seem
almost as big with her it levels the
playing field
yeah like man he really wants you could
feel inner rage yeah you know and yeah
man it does look shot beautifully um
from the trailer and seeing this it
looks like this the cinematography looks
excellent the other trailers give me
that sense it's a well shot scene but
it's not like oh my god like there
aren't any shots in the scene where I'm
like wow that's an image but it's it's
well shot you don't get excited for
anything anymore do you
I do listen guys if you're new the
channel you can subscribe today become a
reject Jerry has the playlist on this
channel watch those videos win today
reject vids featuring Jerry I I just
don't want to see this I'm still gonna
be there and I just don't want to have
fun I still want this to be cool
mm-hmm no shoutouts today people oh no
Jerry ruined it for everyone I think you
know don't make people hate it for
everyone you know what I'm gonna go you
can stay
sure I like the color who gives an all
right clip that's fine this is the same
clip I've seen a hundred times plus
three more lines of dialogue it's just
as cool as it was